tú te levantas todo contento y prendes
el televisor ahora escuchas a un
economista hablar sobre inflación a qué
se refieren bueno pues ellos se refiere
al incremento general en el nivel de los
precios en el nivel de los precios de
bienes y servicios en un periodo de
tiempo los economistas al hablar de
inflación ellos hablan de inflación de
los precios ahora la razón por la que
insisto tanto en esto es porque cuando
la palabra inflación se empezó a usar se
referían a inflación monetaria o al
incremento en la oferta del dinero
entonces yo se referían a inflación
monetaria en la oferta de dinero estas
dos ideas estaban cercanamente
relacionadas pero es muy importante
darse cuenta que las personas lo que
están midiendo cuando hablan de
inflación ellos están hablando sobre
inflación en los precios y si de hecho
están súper relacionadas pero no siempre
significan lo mismo ahora oferta de
dinero esta es más que la cantidad de
billetes que se imprimen porque la
cantidad de billetes impresos este es
afectado por la cantidad de préstamos y
también es afectado a su vez por la
cantidad de transacciones ocurriendo en
esa economía y si la oferta de dinero la
cual es afectada por todas estas cosas
crece más rápido que la productividad
total de la economía entonces esto
ocasionaría una crema
en el nivel de los precios ahora en
otros términos más cortos puede haber
otras causas para tener inflación en los
precios cosas como impactos en la oferta
impactos en la oferta lo cual ocurre
cuando un bien o servicio se vuelve
escaso aún de repente a por ejemplo el
paso en la crisis de petróleo en los
años 70 si por cualquier razón el
petróleo se vuelve escaso en un país
entonces el precio de la gasolina por
ejemplo mínimo aumentaría y digo un
mínimo porque no solamente se afecta el
precio de la gasolina también por
ejemplo una simple banana una tienda
esa banana ahora ya es más cara porque
hubo un transporte de donde se sembró
esa banana de donde se cortó a la tienda
entonces si viajo en no se embarcó troca
o tren pues para todo esto también se
requirió de gasolina como puedes ver el
petróleo afecta muchas cosas una en un
impacto una oferta de petróleo afecta
muchas cosas y bueno como te comento la
oferta de dinero y la inflación en los
precios están bastante relacionados pero
es importante darse cuenta que lo más
común a referirse a cuando te refieres a
inflación es inflación en los precios
en fin la idea general en cierta parte
es bueno la inflación en los precios en
una muy pequeña parte no muy pequeña
parte es buena en una muy pequeña parte
es buena lo voy a poner aquí porque es
importante saber eso y me refiero a una
muy pequeña parte 12 quizás 3% al año
pero algo más alto que eso causa un poco
de miedo porque es algo tenebroso
hablaremos sobre esto en otros vídeos en
un vídeo sobre hiperinflación cuando la
inflación se vuelve salvaje y también
existe la deflación lo cual también
causa temblar a los economistas de esto
también hablaremos en futuros vídeos en
eeuu la inflación se mide con el índice
de precios al consumidor se abrevia ipc
índice de precios al consumidor y
escuchará sobre esto en las noticias por
ejemplo cuando están hablando sobre
negocios finanzas y de hecho hay varias
categorías para el ipc el que se reporta
más cuando dicen o el ipc subió por 2% o
3% normalmente el que se refieren es al
ipc
un ipc donde la u
a consumidor urbano y esta es la más la
más común la más referida porque en el
país casi todo el consumidor es urbano
por lo tanto tenemos que el ipc o el
índice de precios al consumidor urbano
es el que más afecta a los bolsillos y
la manera en que se calcula es como un
deflector es un índice de precios y como
un deflactor está midiendo el incremento
general o cambios generales en el nivel
de los precios aunque si son calculados
en maneras ligeramente diferentes
ahora categorías de ipc que tengan más o
menos el mismo tema o lo mismo que ver
llegan a acuerdos para calcular porque
el dato exacto en los índices indica el
nivel de los precios el ipc trabaja de
la siguiente manera ellos toman una
canasta de bienes para un tipo de
consumidor por ejemplo este en un año
base año base y tomemos un ejemplo
sencillo digamos que en nuestro pequeño
país el consumidor urbano vamos a tomar
a este consumidor y nos referimos
entonces al ips jong-un que el
consumidor urbano solamente consume dos
cosas por ejemplo en el próximo vídeo
vamos a ver que obviamente
más de dos cosas aquí por ejemplo 60% en
manzanas y el 40% en bananas supongamos
es un ejemplo sencillo en ese año base
supongamos que las manzanas estuvieron
en 100 en 100 y las bananas también
estuvieron por ejemplo en 100 ahora ojo
no digo que costaban lo mismo estamos
diciendo que gastamos 60% en manzanas y
40% en bananas en ese año base y que en
ese año base 100 es el nivel de los
precios
lo importante es cuánto cambia ese
índice mientras nos movemos a otro año
donde queramos calcular la inflación
respecto claramente al año base que
tenemos así que tomemos a nuestro año
actual puede ser este justamente el
siguiente el año base que tenemos y
vamos a suponer que estamos igual
gastando 60 por ciento en manzanas y 40
por ciento en bananas en el año actual
el índice de manzanas digamos que 150
entonces subió más más 50 por ciento y
supongamos que en el de bananas creció a
180 entonces más 80 por ciento
ahora como puedes ver las bananas están
mucho más caras
entonces cómo me diríamos el ipc y como
me diríamos su crecimiento lo que
haríamos es tomar un promedio de estos
índices lo puedes llamar una una medida
promedio del crecimiento así que
hagámoslo de ambas maneras verás que
obtendremos el mismo resultado en este
año base es punto 6% más punto 4% eso es
igual a 100 bueno como debe ser de hecho
jay esa es nuestra base para el índice
ahora veamos que tenemos por aquí en
nuestro año actual hacia aquí en este
año actual hacia acá hacemos la
transición hay varias maneras de hacerlo
lo que puede decir es mira gastamos 60
por ciento en algo que subió a 150
diríamos 0.6 por ciento 50 0.6 por
ciento 50 más más 0.4 por ciento 80 eso
nos da cuánto nos da sacamos la
calculadora es punto punto 6 por ciento
cincuenta 150 más
punto 4 por 180 es igual a 162 162
si ves esta canasta esta canasta que es
bastante sencilla aquí hemos
incrementado de 100 de 100 a 162 de 100
a 162 o lo que es lo mismo más 62%
observa que obtenemos lo mismo si
tomamos el promedio de los porcentajes
punto 6 por 50% más punto 4 por 80%
punto 6 por 50%
eso es 30% punto 4 por 80% de esos 32 %
30 32 es igual a 62 por ciento wow nos
da lo mismo da lo mismo en crecimiento
para esta canasta en el consumidor
urbano con un año base a nuestro año
actual en el siguiente vídeo le
echaremos un vistazo a una canasta de
bienes como se ve en realidad para un
consumidor urbano